months of shutdowns during the pandemic
have made it difficult for many small
businesses to stay open and the tourist
business is one of the most
affected but about 150 miles northwest
of new york city
one couple managed to save their
business by offering a one-of-a-kind
experience that you have to see
to believe using their creativity to
transport guests into a
fantastical world
welcome to the roxbury at stratton falls
everyone needs an escape
they need an escape from life from
everything and now even more so
a hotel unlike any other owned by couple
gregory henderson
and joseph masa there's something i
think intrinsic
and human the human experience that
needs entertainment i mean entertainment
has been around since day one right
so even in a hotel room even in a hotel
and when it's in you like it's in us i
mean some people provide
hair extensions we provide like reality
extensions
the roxbury's eight cottages all feature
one-of-a-kind architectural detail
every inch of the two-bedroom
two-bathroom show places
a feast for the eyes take the crown of
pendragon cottage
where king arthur's court meets game of
thrones
you feel like you're inside of a turret
with a 20-foot
three-tiered crown chandelier that we
designed hanging above
a circular bathtub with secret
passageways of these
dru wood looking figures where you find
a shower with body sprays in the toilet
room
in the superhero incognito there's a
wonder woman comic book vibe
combined with pure power we wanted it to
be
about paying tribute and honoring all
women of all races and all body types
that were all superheroes right and
cinderella's gown is all whimsy and
fantasy
even past the stroke of midnight this
amazing bathroom pumpkin
that joseph created every inch of
himself the shape of the pumpkin is
totally
uh done with insulation and spray foam
and it was
it was and then i did a lot of cruelty
steps all sorts of carving
why all the theatrics henderson and masa
say
why not they met on an off-broadway
stage 30 years ago
but when both later felt unfulfilled
henderson working on wall street
masa as a scenic carpenter they left new
york city
for the catskills and joseph started
selling real estate and we became
friends with the guy who owned the real
estate company he said there's this
little
10-unit strip motel in roxbury new york
that has been vacant for a while and the
area desperately needs lodging
the roxbury motel was born in 2004 with
rooms inspired by 60s and 70s pop
culture
ten years later another opportunity
presented itself
when the owner of this property offered
to sell to henderson and masa
any doubt they had erased the moment
they set eyes on its waterfall
and i turned to joe and we looked at
each other and it was like
it was like being in a fairy tale
and that was really the inspiration then
for these cottages
correct yes yeah to build something
magical
where and fairy tale s that transports
people
into this other realm of reality like we
kind of were
that day we're pouring concrete after
five years of hand-designed detailing
their storybook
came to life the roxbury at stratton
falls was set to open in january
a fairy tale ending if not for one big
wrinkle
you open and there's a pandemic governor
cuomo
i'll never forget i was in one of the
mansion rooms and he made the
announcement
so we're going to put out an executive
order today
new york state on pause and my stomach
just
sank by mid april we were thinking
we might have to file bankruptcy the
roxbury did receive a federal paycheck
protection program loan
but that covered payroll not all their
operating costs
you're pretty creative from what i
understand to try to
stay afloat we knew that there would be
some people that would probably buy a
gift certificate
but then i thought what if we do a
program where
we offer 150 value
so if you buy a 100 gift certificate
it's actually worth 150 if a thousand
dollars it's 1500
and i just put it on social media on
instagram and facebook as the first step
speech the response was just
overwhelming i mean it was like within
two days we could pay our utility bills
and and and there was hope i will be
forever
grateful to our repeat guests i will
always
always be grateful to them
[Music]
i've never been in a place where i've
been treated with so much respect
love and dignity than this place never
mimi vega simsik is one of those repeat
guests
her annual trips to the original
property began more than a decade ago
this space changes your life it changes
your energy
it recharges you did you need them even
more now
yes absolutely if i had long money
i would be here every other weekend or i
would have them build me a little shack
on the side
and i could stay there and just admire
everybody the roxbury has
rigorous coveted safety protocols in
place
from cleaning and disinfecting to social
distancing
including a reservation system for its
pool
with their guests back henderson and
masa are getting back on script
focusing on the finishing touches for
their final cottage
the fairy forest after all
without one no storybook would be
complete
the waterfall that inspired this
how often do you get to go down there
and just think about what
it helped to create not not enough
during the worst of the co-work it was
like a ghost town and nobody was here
just a few of us working i went down
there a lot more
then just to kind of remind myself
why we're here and what we're doing and
it would give you a little
okay i can deal with this so going
forward
what is that business plan at least in
the next i think
it i think we're going to be fine and
i'd like to think that it goes beyond
just the fact that people are coming
here because of covet and they can't
fly to paris it's also because they want
that
that reality extension they want that
right total fantasy
and that was part of the concept from
the beginning forget about covert so
i i think that's still going to bring
people here
i loved his description when he said the
reality extension you know some people
get hair extensions we're doing a
reality extension
because it is that you're looking just
something to take you away for a little
bit
there's galileo's cottage there's a
greek cottage
it really is an escape for everybody
yeah we all want that long
money but i have to tell you broke the
website just now i'm trying to get on a
book
yeah you've been trying to do it for
weeks now i know part of their coveted
protocols are
if somebody's staying in a room the next
day they want it sitting for 24 hours
before they go in to clean
and they do all the cleaning process so
they're not even at full capacity right
now
but again all because they want to keep
people safe and stay open forever
yeah get get ready it looks like a
different world and the number of hotel
owners and restaurant owners we've
talked to
who have relied on those repeat
customers and those loyal customers
the gratefulness they're showing for
them it's amazing to see a newbie
customer right here